i'm going to get a bottle of wine
[Music]
this is canada it's supposed to be a
free country i'm here to protest you
know
we have the right to protest that's one
thing now we even been denied the places
to protest we went farther down and the
police chased us away i'm here for my
freedom and it's not over until it's
over so
we're told to stand on guard and that's
what we're doing standing
it's unreal it would be nice to have a
little bit more support from the police
but
i guess it comes down to this i think
it's ridiculous all this our taxpayer
dollars oh my goodness you know this is
not what we put our tax
money out for
all these police officers and they're
turning it into a communistic system
especially trudeau and ford you can't
help but notice you know the uh the
prime minister justin trudeau
um takes a knee in solidarity with uh
with with other groups radical groups
and um
and yeah he doesn't even he cowers he
cowers when we we the people are
speaking so yeah it really doesn't
reflect well on our on our leaders
ontario and a lot of canadians are fed
up with the mandates they're fed up with
the restrictions and
i think a lot of people just want to go
back to living their lives it's not so
much about mandate it's all about
people's opinions people's rights and
people's free will
and that's what i'm here to support it's
come to the point where it's up to us
people to do this if they want to arrest
me i'm 83 years old go ahead arrest me
you know
because
one thing is
our generation our youth and everything
this should have a freedom we shouldn't
force them to get a jab and all those
things you know i do think it's going to
continue because you know there's a lot
of people that really believe strongly
in what's going on down here yeah we
just need to regroup